er werde nicht der war nicht ich habe
nur ein paar löcher rein geschrieben
[Musik]
ich hoffe euch geht es gut mir geht's
super angefangen auf jeden fall was geht
ihr habt schon gelesen heute gibt es den
lang ersehnten paar letztes kann er noch
irgendwie gegentrend von jungs die
mädchen hatten dass jeder total gut
angekommen hat mich persönlich sehr
gefreut doch 20.000 likes mal sehen ob
das bei diesem video auf schaffen oder
sogar über 20 bestimmen welcher davon
vor eine reizung gesagt es wird auch zu
dieser reihe im video geben einfach nur
zehn mädchen trennen die jungs toll
finden die jungs gehen auf die jungs
voll abfahren und dem titel stehe
wahrscheinlich zehn mädchen trennen
die jungs lieben lässt sich dieser titel
nicht schön eindeutig auf die entfall
die jungs und natürlich auch ein paar
mädchen haben ja auch geschrieben auf
netzwerk gefragt wie seht ihr das ich
hab das gerät zu bekommen
das meiste war zwar irgendwie das
gleiche wo ich mir zum teil auch dachte
also das kann ich erst mal vorweg
ansprechen ich weiß japan snap halten
wir nicht folgt es auf jeden fall mal
und endet mich da und schickt ein paar
geile snaptu auf jeden fall habe ich
festnetz auch viele die sie noch etwas
jünger 12 13 14 15 will ich mal jetzt
auch noch etwas jüngeren auch wenn es
ein gesundes mittelmaß ist was meine
zuschauer reichweite angeht manche sind
auch ernsthaft das habe ich jetzt auch
mal gesehen ich habe euch nämlich
aufforderung irgendein video zu
schreiben und erst man wirklich viele in
der grundschule aber geil
na ja auf jeden fall haben viele
geschrieben jo mädchen trennten jungs
liegen hundeführer bei cnet adidas
superstars durch mir dachte da gibt sie
erst besser mal keinen kommentar dazu ab
in deinem alter also um ehrlich zu sein
ich weiß es gibt verschiedene
interessengruppen und an die mädchen
es ist anfang wirklich so dass viele
jungs im alter von 14 15 jahre alter
superstar wirklich abfeiern
auch wenn ich schon total aus sind am
anfang fand ich hier auch gut aber
mittlerweile hier einfach so auf die
eier wenn ich diese schuhe sehe ich kein
trotzen
ohne zeit es ist jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen hart wenn ihr die noch störend
ist mir das natürlich egal und zum hunde
filter will ich jetzt gar nicht sagen ja
das hab ich glaube ich im netz wieder
schon angesprochen also das war wächst
nur die zwei punkte die ich so oft
geredet habe wo ich mir dachte leute hab
ich ihr also wir fangen ich hab mich ein
paar punkte die mir auch zugeschickt
haften teilhabe für natürlich auch
selber ausgesucht wo ich komplett hinter
stehe das jetzt und ich will gar nicht
lange wand wir fangen sofort man mit
punkt nummer eins der herren sofort
eingefallen ist das ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich bei mir so ich denke ich
immer so viele nacktbilder auf nette
bekomme mädchen dann keinen kleinen
unterhosen und sonnenschein haben
eigentlich ob ständiger ingo klein war
natürlich nur ein spaß also ab und zu
schicken mir irgendwelche mädchen dann
natürlich aber was wo ich mir denke york
läuft war hier aber da wollen wir jetzt
gar nicht darauf eingehen und das sind
dann meistens auch seien ältere also
eine jüngere nehmt euch das jetzt nicht
als beispiel aber calvin klein
unterwäsche ist natürlich klar im trend
und ich würde jetzt einfach mal
verallgemeinert sagen dass findet
eigentlich jeder junge ganz attraktiv
das dann auch wirklich sehr viele von
euch geschrieben und deswegen
reingenommen calvin klein muss sein
träger das einzige rein also man muss
natürlich nicht so ein tag so machen wir
weiter mit den nächsten punkt so bin ich
da jetzt absolut das geweih das ist also
ein trend also jungs findet sehr
attraktiv und fahren voll auf ab wenn
mädchen alexy schauen
kassel wird sich gar nicht mehr das denn
geschickt keiner ist jetzt nur leicht
unangenehme situation für mich hier
wundert euch bitte nicht über die laute
musik im hintergrund irgendjemand
vielleicht mein bruder hat laut musiker
du nicht sag doch wollte mir auch wäre
auf geschick stecher auch kompletten tag
und war wenn man so seinen ersten freund
hat macht man das hier natürlich sehr
gerne und zwar klauten dann mal den
einen pulli wo ich finde so pullover
stehen mädchen eigentlich genauso gut
also so wie viele mädchen tragen ja
mittlerweile auch einfach solide obwohl
die denke ich mal ursprünglich mehr so
als jungs mode gesehen wurden vor drei
jahren oder so ich will auf jeden fall
mädchen
mindestens genauso gut tragen und das
ist ja dann der boyfriend look also
viele ausdrücke habe ich bekommen zum
beispiel laptops oder so mit denen
konnte ich überhaupt nichts anfangen
aber beim boyfriend look weil ich auch
was gemeint ist also ich könnte ja
eigentlich immer dann bilder dazu ein
werden weil ihr habt auch fcb liegt
letztlich zum nächsten punkt wo ich
eigentlich auch hinter spielt da wäre
ich gar nicht drauf gekommen aber diese
etwas erotischen netzstrumpfhose familie
wirklich sehr viele jungs geschickt und
ländern hatte zuvor das ist so geil wenn
man hier dann irgendwie ein bisschen
höher hat oder unter einer dienstag hat
volker drin bin und da habe ich mir
gedacht du hast recht also so was
ungefähr hier halt und von vielen
mädchen habe ich auch bilder bekommen
von irgendwelchen frisuren wohl wie
meinen er wirklich viele mädchen tragen
solche frisuren mit zu zentral und das
finden bestimmt viele jungs cool wo ich
mir dachte ja das könnte sein also
jemand bild was ich wirklich sehr schön
fand und ich kenne auch viele mädchen
die das ab und zu übertragen sogar meine
freundin macht es ja auch manchmal
solche schönen sätze also den einsatz
macht an sie und in anderen nicht und
wer eine sie dann auch wirklich gut aus
an denen wenig gemacht hat der mieter
also eine jungs sie findet ihr solche
frisuren killisch oder also ich fand
konnte ob die nächste trend sind ja
diese löcher in hohem tempo ließ blaue
war ich habe auch sehr viele polit wird
er wahrscheinlich mit sämtlichen löchern
wo ich mittlerweile denke das sind mir
zu viele löcher so was finde ich wär
cool was wurden angeht und noch drin vor
allem bei mädchen finden viele jungs
glaube ich ziemlich ziemlich attraktiv
und deswegen durchaus auch mit einem
video nebauer diese kraft zerstrittenen
politiker wieder eine andere waffe also
bitte nicht euer ganzes aus wird nur
weil ihr hängt das ist gerade voll in
ich glaube der trend ist schon wieder so
ein bisschen vorbei also so hiermann hat
und jemand hat das ok aber nicht hier
hier hier hier hier hier hier hier hier
und die partie dann im endeffekt so aus
keiner politik nicht angebracht hier
seht ihr nicht der angst ich habe nur
ein paar löcher rein geschrieben so
leute
machen weiter und zwar hab ich noch
folgendes bild bekommen zwar gleich mal
kurz ein
wenn man im winter locken oder stiefel
die bis über die da verstehe ich jetzt
dass deutsch nicht wenn man im winter
sockeln oder stiefel die bis über die
hohen strumpfhose gehen trägt also
wahrscheinlich eine sturm vor wann hat
darüber locken und dann auch stiefel wo
man die socken aber über 70 einfach das
bild an ich weiß es nicht erklären weil
das tragen aber ziemlich viele
einzelfragen aber auf jeden fall
ziemlich viele mädchen so als wäre es
häufiger mal und dann kann ich auch
komplett hinter mir stehen darauf an
bestimmt viele jungs ab und eine etwas
jüngere zuschauerinnen von mir auch
folgendes geschrieben
da war ich auch der überraschungs war
also anfang 2016 mal alle geschminkt wie
sonst was dann im laufe des jahres auch
jetzt weder knicks das würde sagen 1
endlich auch mal ungeschminkte zeigen
und sich zu zeigen die man sich egal was
andere sagen
das hat mich sehr mitgenommen eigentlich
nicht aber dazu kann ich folgendes sagen
ich glaube so wenn man jetzt vielleicht
schon in mainz heißt ich bin jetzt von
sitze es interessiert mich mal schätzer
bitte in den kommentaren wie einzig so
geradeaus
ich meine ich jetzt nicht wirklich
erwachsen oder ich sehe mich immer noch
einen kleinen jungen der bisher in süsel
will er auf jeden fall so die etwas
jüngeren findet natürlich glaube ich
immer cool wenn mich ein komplett
geschminkt sind und wenn man ein
bisschen leiser wird denkt man sich so
ungeschminkt ist eigentlich auch coop
lama hier ein bisschen schminke und da
ein bisschen schminke ist natürlich voll
okay aber die natürlichkeit deuten ii
verloren gehen vor allem wenn man dann
schon vielleicht jetzt nicht so viele
pickel hat und aus der pubertät ein
bisschen raus und da kann ich auch für
viele jungs sprechen dass dann
vielleicht natürlich ist sich nicht so
krass zu schwingen sei mit euch selber
zufrieden und zeigt euch so wie ihr seid
zitat alex wie 2010
februar als die alte strecke mitte auf
jeden fall in die kommentare was ihr so
bei jungs trends feiert als mädchen das
nächste mal durch und macht abzuwenden
auf dem video und direkt für mich wenn
ich nicht wild wahrscheinlich wissens
meine hardcore zuschauer auch ja aber
trotzdem stets an die kommentare aber
nicht vergessen
wir sehen uns montag wieder also morgens
von hat ein schnäppchen instagram music
lissabon ihre mich und das letzte 4